[Music]
hello everyone I'm really glad that you
came to here and talked about the new
parser coming for note a bit about Who I
am further in that knee here is my
Twitter and github handles which are
quite the same and I write code at
PayPal you might know me by this
Darkseid's avatar from DC Comics that I
use on both Twitter and github and
practically everywhere else so it's for
today's talk the slides of the
presentations are already available
online so if you would like you can scan
the QR code and open it in your browser
and just follow along as I'm going to
present the topic which is LL HTTP the
new HTTP portion one protocol parser for
no GS this topic of course has deep
roots into the history of non GS and it
would be hard if not impossible to not
mention the history while describing it
of course not GS recently is used a lot
for front-end tooling but originally
historically it started as a back-end
platform it was exclusively about
building a synchronous HTTP servers
it is then unsurprising that quoting
Ryan doll as a creator of note that HTTP
parser is what star is a node there have
been a lot of presentations on
importance in a role in internal
structure of lis bv it's a personal GS
event loop and is a key core company
that makes ever since pin instead of the
node and you might be wondering if Libby
is all this dependency however it is not
as a HTTP parser
is all those dependencies that not ever
had so had it has actually of leaves a
lot of dependencies and note initially
it was inspired by mongrel which is a
ruby web server with its own parser
created by that show later there were
some parts of nginx code introduced in
HTTP parsers original one and of course
a lot of original called by Ryan himself
the parser has been with us since 2009
so it's been open 10 years
in fact note itself has been introduced
at this very conference ten years ago by
Ryan so it's kind of a jubilee for both
of those projects and to celebrate this
I wrote another HTTP parser to replace
the original parser so why would anyone
want to get rid of such library of
course it's a fantastic library it has
been with us for ten years so it should
have been worked fine and it has many
users aside of knowledge es community as
well for example Android proxy by Google
they use it for parsing HTP requests and
it's quite popular project as well so
what makes this parser so great and how
did stay with us for so long
first of all it has good enough
performance what this means is that it
takes a quite a lot of time to invoke a
c function from javascript and parse
residency and it takes way way less time
to parse the request i'm going to
elaborate on it's a bit later in this
presentation but for node.js purposes
it's very good performance so it
couldn't be better
it also supports a lot of clients and
servers that violate the HTTP
specification and there are way too many
of them out in the internet you would be
surprised how many and of course
supporting design was very important for
early adoption of knowledge yes because
in 2009 there was even more such clients
and servers out there another point is
that original parser has a lot of test
Suites over ten years
Ryan ban and other maintainer of the
project including myself I wrote quite a
comprehensive test suite that covers
almost every aspect of HTTP
specification so the parser is well
tested so that was a good points of
original parser now we come to other
points and fortunately with the age of
the library the code became quite rigid
it became impossible to move things
around to make significant changes to it
and in the consequence of this it became
impossible to maintain this library
efficiently furthermore as one of the
maintainer such approach
I have to constantly relearn and get
familiar with parts of the code base
that I was previously familiar familiar
before and I did it on every pull
request and still I wasn't sure if the
code is going to run in the way I expect
it to run so it could introduce some
unexpected behavior even though I
checked it or maybe a security
vulnerability as well which is obviously
bad it doesn't help either that most
noches users and developers are familiar
with JavaScript and are more comfortable
with it then they are we see so there is
not too many people interested in
working on this HTTP parser with all
this in mind several years ago I have
set on a quest to make the library
better and maybe a bit faster in the
process first attempts were quite
conservative so I tried to state with
existing code as much as possible and
some of them were successful like
replacing the parts of state machine
with macros and using them consistently
just not only improve the code but also
made it faster which was nice
other attempts were a complete disaster
I tried to move those states into a
separate function and just call them
from the loop so each state would return
the next state that is supposed to be
executed and then the loop would run
that function for Asus completely ruins
the performance and I never contributed
it or send it to upstream from this
attempts both a successive or failure
the conclusion was clear it was hard to
make an improvement while staying with
existing code base and if there was no
requirement to reuse as much code as
possible then it was no longer necessary
to develop the library in the same
programming language as before so why
not develop it in JavaScript or maybe
typescript instead and that of course
JavaScript performance is quite great
but you wouldn't be surprised that
slower than C and it takes a lot of
effort to reach comparable performance
as the C libraries when you write
programs in JavaScript takes a lot of
effort but it's possible so I wanted to
get this performance optimization out of
consideration
and those I decided to just define the
parser in typescript and still compile
it down to AC library so the end result
would still be C libraries that could be
used in node in other projects and which
is great because existing users of HTTP
parser this way would be able to
transition their code to the new parser
and hopefully in the process and the
performance would not degrade too much
because in the end it's running the same
programming language so yes good changes
have been chances of being the same
speed so loz TP is in a way in the next
major version of HTTP parser it has the
same core principles and similar api
which is almost identical in the way the
balls work is that they scan requests
one character at a time and during this
process they change the internal state
and they also could imagine either
fields or maybe header values and later
on body and not sure if you're going to
wait for this it's quite slow okay yeah
I think you probably understand what it
means now at least some extent
so this resists cannon and by the virtue
of this one by one as can the parser can
work without buffering anything at all
so it doesn't allocate memory itself and
it's creates especially for the request
bodies because it it could just meet the
slices of original buffers that came
from that work instead of allocating and
copying data so it's in core principles
of the HT parser it is that it's not
copying it's important as soon as any
amount of data basically arrives from
network be the health request or even a
single byte of the request HTTP parser
is ready to process it and it will emit
possibly partial because it could be
health request the header names and
values may be she values we just seen in
this animation in the original version
of the parser this scan was quite
naturally implemented over the in the
for loop over the input so it was just
going through the inputs byte by byte
and
doing some syncs and what it did is
actually it was described by huge switch
statement over all possible person
states so whether it's a Heather named
Heather well you maybe it's well you of
content lengths Heather it was all
described by the switch statement and
different clauses of the switch
statement we were representing different
states of the barsen of the state
machine all of this lived in a single
function over one thousand of lines of
code which is quite a terrible idea the
obvious improvement would be to break
this switch into pieces and make it such
that each piece has precise action in
sort of a UNIX philosophy I guess so it
would be just exactly about doing one
small thing at a time
go-to statements would be used just jump
between states so there would not be a
much neaten using this for loop as it's
not as much so with all this in mind how
exactly did I approach this process I
have developed domain-specific language
or a DSL for short and developed it in
typescript and created the compiler
around it which is called allow parse so
it's again double L and this compiler is
used to describe the parsing States in
terms of these actions that they perform
so each state would have several actions
assigned to them and they would perform
them and move on to next state when it's
ready because this a lot of ours is
quite general compiler it can be used
for other protocols as well and works by
the for textual protocols but still I
think could be useful original parsers
suffered from surplus of handwritten
code so I have selected a few actions
that were repeated most in the original
library in main DSL around them the idea
here is that I wanted the description of
the new parser in this DSL to be concise
so I wanted to write the code with last
lines and vise seamless as possible so I
wanted to move the most common
operations inside of the compiler so
that the rest would don't have to do
this work all over again and repeat it
as it was an original parser
here is a few methods this compiler
supports one of them is match it takes a
sequence or a character of bytes and it
tries to match them from the input a for
example could be keepalive which is
where well you have the header named
connection it's quite common header and
very important so it could match this
sequence and when it does move to the
next state by taking the reference to
this state at other times the parser
needs to check the next character in the
incoming data without actually consuming
it and peak could be used for this so it
takes a single character just matches it
an input and moves on without making any
other work so without moving forward in
the input stream and speaking of headers
headers like content links they have
injurer well is which frankly described
by shrinks because it's a textual
protocol so the new parser has to be
able to parse the integer of strings and
a way to do it this way I decided to do
it is to implement this select method
and DSL which takes a map as an input
and this map has sequences or characters
as a keys and the integers as well is so
it tries to map this sequences to the
integers and just pass these values
along to the next state the next state
could be storing just those integers
inside of some property of the C
structure or it could be maybe in
walking a user called back with them
speaking of callbacks there is one
special type of callbacks it is very
important in the life span of both
original and the newest tree parser so
during their executions they meet ranges
of data for example header names or
heddle well or header well you're
supposed immediate in this way and given
that we have a stream of data that comes
to the parser we have to be able to mark
some certain place inside the stream as
the beginning of this range and then at
some other points later on we want to
set it as a end
I was arranged so between those
beginning and ending or if you say that
are beginning and ended between them the
callback is going to be invoked for
every bite it's really really useful for
header names had or well use for bodies
and other sinks that could be me the
suspense ranges of input of course there
are a couple of important actions that I
have immediate in previous slides and
that are actually mandatory to have in
the states they called otherwise and
skip two and those specify which states
of the parser should be reached next if
nothing else matches inside of the
current state so in this example if the
input would be a the parser would move
to the child a state for the B it will
move to Chell B and if it will be C or D
or E or whatever so later it will move
to some other state skip two is quite
similar it does exactly the same scene
but it consumes the character from the
input stream so otherwise does not
change inputs rheumatologist moves on so
that was a bit of description maybe too
concise to be useful of the DSL and with
this DSL mind HTTP becomes a type script
program and this typescript program uses
these self defines the parsing States
and describe their actions and input has
said before and because it's the
typescript program or JavaScript program
really I could split it in several sub
modules and use them efficiently and
each sub module could represent a subpar
sir and in fact this is what I use in
LCP I have a separate URL parser inside
of it and I can test it separately I can
run it separately and actually could be
used separately as well just the
separate library if anyone wants it so
GPOs are all parts of all of SS
all parse transpile this typescript
program time down to C and that's the
main action of it note that because it
uses a stable DSL oh sorry it's just use
this cell the compiler doesn't need
any parser or syndics checking it is
done automatically by the jeaious engine
so v8 does it for us so v8 just execute
this DSL and internally our parse builds
a graph of states which I will try to
show you it looks kind of terrible but I
probably can zoom in yeah so yeah so
here how it looks like in practice
i I can probably actually show you in
something more useful so here on the
right you see a CL by and check out it's
probably the small but it's method names
that are supported by parser and then
the method name is matched inside of the
input it will store the integer encoding
as a method inside of the property of
internal poverty of the parser [ __ ]
works works this way more or less and I
guess that means this kind of graph is
looking awesome
so it's one reason to have it another
reason to have it is that all parts can
do static analysis on this graph before
in original parsers there was no way to
reason about the states automatically so
Z was all described manually instead
with the parser versus just a lot of C
code and there was no way to analyze it
and doing optimizations to checks what I
can do in all parts is check the graph
for absence of infinite loops which is
possible to get so otherwise and peek so
they could be combined together just not
making any progress over the input and
just spin indefinitely and of course
it's very important to check this
aesthetically because there might be
some risk or some very rare conditions
that could trigger it in line and said
not might be might be not immediately
very file always a test seat
speaking of optimizations the parser
could do peephole optimizations and
fancy name for just combined and similar
states together into one this way the
amount of generate code is reduced and
also compiler a programmer has a lot
more freedom and development apart
because they don't have to sync about
doing these optimizations manual in
there
so as I said the t-cell is quite stable
for L VARs so same program could be
compiler to different outputs at this
moment C and LOV M is called a boss
supported and a lot of the M bit code
was kind of before it was supported
before the C so that's the reason why
most projects have double L in their
names and kind of historical reason but
in the end when I ran benchmarks it
turns out that this trivial C compiler
worked faster than LOV n bit code which
I spent several weeks on yeah it was
quite surprising for me and maybe
shocking so it took a few months to
think about it
yeah and speaking of performance you
might be wondering how fast this new
parser is given that this not n reason
at all but of course despite the
maintenance issues as I said before the
original she parser has very good
performance
the good enough but still very good it
would have been very and reasonable to
replace it with some sense that
performed significant and significantly
worse so LS g p is not handwritten it's
not hand optimized and when I ran
benchmarks I discovered that the rhymes
the runs twice as fast as original
parser
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you and here is actual benchmark
numbers so as you can see both those
numbers are quite wild it's a as a
represents the number of requests per
second that each parser can take and
this way both parsers run unless and
microseconds so you one wouldn't ever
see this on the profile looks just
impossible to see it of course it's
quite evident as well that LSD peas were
more than two times faster than original
parser and but note hardly cares about
it this HTTP parser is the default HTTP
parser in old version 12 so if you are
using the latest note I hope you do you
are already running this and even more
you have a reason to blame me for any
kind of which to be problems that they
have so feel free to do so and you would
be it will be rightful foot to the sole
so please open the github issues though
so don't just bragging Twitter about how
bad I am and tag me on github I will be
happy to look into it and fix it as soon
as possible as I said before over 10
years original SEO parser has
accumulated a comprehensive test suite
it would be really unwise to get rid of
it and just start over so I poured it
all original tests to markdown and added
a few new ones and you heard right they
described by the markdown files so I
completely textual and I encourage you
to take a look at them if you want
because I find them the most amusing
part of the project their work on yes a
really really fun I'm going to give a
bit more time because I see that some
people scan the calls okay so that makes
us and each markdown file contains
several tests they separated by the
headings so it's quite easy through it
and even easier to contribute in fact I
had one contributors that submitted the
test without even asking me a question
how to do so even though I
don't know that many projects that use
this test system that is easy to
contribute and furthermore each test has
a textual description side of them so
they have a code chunks inside of
markdown kolchak for input called chunk
for expected output and between those
you can put just any text you want you
can put hyperlinks you could put images
you can put gifs of pets doing stuff so
it's quite quite nice way of writing
tests and it especially works well for
HTTP because it's the textual protocol
so you can read the request there and
see what is actually fent inside the
test sheet yeah so here's been the
presence of the parser and the history
of it so it's naturally I would like to
talk about what's coming next
and there is a room for future
improvements with regards to doing more
static checks and this graph that I
showed to you and doing more performance
optimizations
there are Forks of original GT parser
that use CPU specific vector
instructions which were really really
real fast and they perform much better
than boss allows to be an original
parser there is not much useful speed
bump for note but nevertheless there's
no reason to not explore it so I I
probably should do it or I would love to
see someone doing it for me to be
awesome
quite shaming Lee the project is not so
well documented at the moment it has
considerable amount of trades dog
describing the API of all pars in detail
but it's kind of scatter it through
several dependences and could be made
much more accessible I would truly
appreciate how pieces and I'm sure that
some people might find this quite
entertaining as well because there's a
lot of interesting moments in its parser
and it's code finally it would be
fascinating to see different types of
parsers implemented on top of our parse
this cell it's two examples that I have
in mind SMTP and pop3 protocol so they
both are textual and could be
implemented quite efficiently I think in
all pars so I really look forward to
either working on this or helping
someone with this
and yeah here is linked to the LLC P
repository is it's actually quite easy
to find on github which just leaves
under an ulti s organization so it's
github.com slash knowledge s / / / ll
HTTP so I guess that's it so thank you
so much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]